c'est moi le papa de ces merveilleux
trois enfants le comédien jean nicolas
verreault et sa conjointe génie karina
nous ouvrent les portes de leurs
familles de leurs maisons et de leurs
cours au moment où il se lance dans la
construction de nouveaux havre de paix
minimes à bamako mais il ne s'agit pas
ici d'une deuxième série documentaire ou
disait d'être et 9 leur maison non
l'accord est plein c'est d'abord et
avant tout une touchante aventure email
on note grande motte et qui elle surtout
d'énormément nak cité l'ex et
orthographiques ce calcul qui lui a le
finalement défaut d'attention mal le
syndrome de gilles de la tourette remis
à le syndrome de nageurs syndrome qui
confèrent des malformations
craniofaciale malgré les défis auxquels
ils font face on découvre une famille
soudée et rempli d'amour quand l'idée de
la série est apparu est ce que vous avez
une des craintes des hésitations à
participer je veux des cannes parce que
je sais que ça peut très intrusif dans
un document j'ai fini par comprendre
tranquillement
la portée que ça pouvait arriver au top
oui pour nous comme familles vont les
autres familles pis pour le futur de nos
feuilles ou si c'est d'ouvrir la porte
sans filtre puis les gens vont nous voir
vivre
je pense que juste de voir ce qui peut
se passer dans la maison de quelqu'un
d'eau d'être un peu 5 voyant mes devoirs
c'est très apaisant je pense je pense
qu'un show qui montrent que on doit
toujours comme continuer à être dans
l'action de bougies trouver les choses
pour chercher c'est un jour où on
accepte de montrer qu'on est tous
imparfaits qui en a pas de famille
parfaite
moi ce qui m'a particulièrement plu dans
la série c'est l'authenticité puis le
fait que rarement dans des téléréalités
ou dans des documentaires on voit des
gens souffrir comme ça sans fil et
pourtant je pense que c'est le genre de
chose dont on a besoin si on veut vivre
dans une société plus tolérante plus
inclusive donc vraiment pour ça chapeau
régulier possible vu la série toi tu
sais ça doit passer
moi je pense que tout parent devrait au
moins voir le premier épisode parce que
je suis un bel exemple de résilience
d'un amour est fini pour ses enfants on
n'est pas dans ce jugement puisse
vraiment saluer la réalisation de cette
série là c'est magnifique
bravo c'est à découvrir sur ici tou tv
ça s'appelle la cour est pleine
ici n'est dit alexandre charti et louis
philippe ouimet radio canada montréal